لأول مرة منذ اندلاع الأزمة الملكية
في الأردن خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ،
سمع الناس من ملكهم يخاطب
الأمة
في رسالة إلى الناس يطمئنهم
فيها أن
بلدهم مستقر وأنه آمن ، قال إن
الاقتباس من الفتنة
قد تم القضاء عليه في مهدها.  وقال
إن التحدي خلال الأيام القليلة الماضية
لم يكن الأصعب أو الخطير
على استقرار أمتنا ،
لكن بالنسبة لي كانت الفتنة الأكثر إيلاما
أتت من داخل
منزلنا ومن خارجه ولا شيء
يضاهي
الصدمة والألم والغضب الذي أصابني.  أخ
وزعيم الأسرة الهاشمية
هناك بالطبع
يشير إلى ما وصفته الحكومة
بمؤامرة مزعومة
تتهم أخيه غير الشقيق
ولي العهد السابق الأمير حمزة
بن الحسين أفراد آخرين
في البلد أيضًا بالعمل
معهم.  كيانات أجنبية تتآمر
لزعزعة استقرار البلاد وهو
أمر
نفاه الأمير حمزة قائلا إنه
ليس جزء من أي
مؤامرة أه أجنبية الآن.  في
الأيام القليلة الماضية ، كان هناك الكثير من
التكهنات حول الكثير
من الأسئلة حول مكان وجود
الأمير حمزة ما حدث له بعد
تلك الفيديوهات المسربة المثيرة خلال
عطلة نهاية
الأسبوع والتي قال فيها بشكل أساسي إنه
يخضع
فعليًا للإقامة الجبرية و
سمعنا من الملك عبدالله الليلة أن
الأمير حمزة كان في منزله مع
عائلته وقال أقتبس تحت رعايتي
الآن ليس واضحًا تمامًا ما يعنيه ذلك
ولكن ما أوضحه الملك هو أن
قراره
كان التعامل مع الأمير حمزة.  هذا
الوضع
كقضية أسرية فُوض عمه
للتوسط والتعامل معها عندما
يتعلق الأمر ببقية هذه
القضية للتحقيق الذي يقول
إنه مستمر وهو أه سيتم التعامل معه
عن طريق قضاء البلاد
ووعد
أنه سيكون عادلاً
وشفافًا حتى بعد سماع من
ملكهم
الأردني لا يزال لديهم الكثير من الأسئلة
حول أحداث الأيام القليلة الماضية.
لقد أرسلنا موجات صادمة عبر هذا
البلد
وخارجه ، لكن الرسالة كانت
واضحة من
قيادة الأردن ، فهم يريدون وضع هذا وراءهم ،
فهم يريدون إغلاق هذا الفصل ومحاولة
استعادة صورة هذا البلد
المعروف باستقراره
ووحدته.  العائلة المالكة جوانا
كاراتشاي CNN عمان
العظيمة